[Música]
economía en directo América de Francia
24 Juan Pablo lucumí con nosotros en el
estudio Juan Pablo vamos a iniciar con
la noticia económica del día y es la
reunión entre funcionarios de alto nivel
de China y Estados Unidos Raúl fueron
dos horas y media de reunión en zúrich
al norte de Suiza y aquí destacaremos
algunas de las declaraciones de esta
reunión entre el viceprimer ministro de
China liuji y la secretaria del tesoro
de Estados Unidos Janette para el
funcionario chino es indispensable que
haya una comunicación seria Para
coordinar temas que incluyen el cambio
climático y economía dijo también que
estaba listo para un intercambio más
profundo por su parte la secretaria del
tesoro estadounidense dijo abro comillas
compartimos la responsabilidad de
demostrar que China y Estados Unidos
pueden gestionar nuestras diferencias y
evitar que la competencia se convierta
en algo cercano al conflicto también
aseguró abro comillas en medio de un
panorama económico mundial complicado
existe la necesidad imperante que las
dos mayores economías del mundo
mantengan una estrecha comunicación
sobre la macroeconomía mundial y las
condiciones financieras cierro comilla
en estas dos citas se recoge el
resultado de esta reunión básicamente
Raúl bueno Juan Pablo y le pregunto que
viene entonces para estos dos países
Raúl Pues un funcionario estadounidense
confirmó ayer martes que el secretario
de estado Anthony blinquen visitará
Beijing a principios de febrero de darse
esta reunión sería el primer secretario
de estado de Estados Unidos en visitar
China desde octubre de 2018 y hoy
también Juan Pablo secretario de la ONU
envió desde precisamente el foro
económico mundial un mensaje directo a
las 12 principales economías del mundo
por supuesto China y Estados Unidos así
de Raúl pues Y eso es lo que estábamos
hablando mientras estaban en esta
reunión que se reunieron como decíamos
en zúrich para estrechar la comunicación
entre ambas partes el secretario general
de las Naciones Unidas Antonio Gutiérrez
pidió desde el foro que tanto china como
Estados Unidos dejen de fomentar la
división entre ambos bandos Gutiérrez
llamó a Esta división como la gran
fractura que según expertos que citó le
podría costar a la economía global 1,4
billones de dólares Esto fue lo que dijo
nos arriesgamos a lo que yo llamo la
gran fractura el desacoplamiento de las
dos economías más grandes del mundo Una
grieta tectónica que crearía dos
conjuntos diferentes de reglas
comerciales Dos monedas dominantes dos
redes de internet y dos estrategias en
conflicto sobre Inteligencia artificial
Esto es lo último que necesitamos Juan
Pablo también hace poco hablamos que
disminuyó la inflación en Estados Unidos
pero ahora también en otra de las
principales economías del mundo parece
que el panorama de la inflación empieza
a mejorar para las principales economías
esta vez hablamos de Reino Unido porque
la inflación cayó al 10,5% interanual en
diciembre de 2022 desde el 10,7% de
noviembre una noticia que le da
Esperanza al banco de Inglaterra pero
que si vemos la tendencia de los últimos
seis meses sigue siendo un ipc bastante
elevado y que apenas empieza a descender
desde el 11,1% anual de octubre cuando
se consagró como el máximo de los
últimos 40 años analistas esperan que la
economía de Reino Unido se contraiga
este año a medida que la inflación
apriete los ingresos disponibles y
también se pronostica que el desempleo
aumente en 2023 a pesar de todo este
panorama negativo para el mundo la gente
sigue viajando y de una manera masiva y
así es la gente sigue viajando sigue
conociendo destinos y pese a la elevada
inflación los rumores de recesión todas
las personas siguen todavía en las
aerolíneas comprando en general las
aerolíneas estadounidenses dicen que
desde los últimos tres meses de 2022 la
demanda de vuelos ha ido en aumento Y
esperan que este año continúe igual y
United Airlines espero hasta las hasta
el cierre de Wall Street de ayer martes
para dar a conocer que sus ganancias e
ingresos fueron superiores a las
expectativas de los inversores
precisamente de Wall Street Juan Pablo
Entonces cuánto fueron las ganancias
United y seguro que los precios también
de los vuelos subieron Y es United ganó
843 millones de dólares entre octubre y
diciembre pero en general los boletos de
aviones están contribuyendo a la
inflación según las cifras del gobierno
de Estados Unidos los pasajeros pagaron
en promedio
25,5% más por milla en 2022 Comparado
con 2021 y un 20,8% más que a finales de
2019 están bastante caros bastante caros
yo creo que ya me dieron ganas de viajar
y mi próximo destino será la Ciudad de
Cali su ciudad Ah bueno ahí estará saber
indicadores económicos iniciamos con
Asia porque las bolsas de ese continente
cerraron con ganancias después de que el
Banco Central de Japón mantuvo sin
cambio su política monetaria permisiva
disipando las especulaciones de que se
debía ante la presión para restringir el
crédito para contrarrestar el aumento de
la inflación las bolsas en Europa siguen
operando también reportando ganancias
con los anuncios optimistas de los
ministros de finanzas y economía muy
presentes las inversiones para el bloque
y los planes de subsidios que esperan
hacerle frente a la inflación de Estados
Unidos fueron bien recibidos así como el
plan Industrial Greenville que anunció
ayer la presidenta de la comisión
europea Úrsula Juan Pablo como siempre
Gracias por toda la información
económica de esta mañana directo América
Así es mañana con más información de
economía y volamos directo hasta París
hablando de vuelos